[ROCKET SHIP]
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: For best
user experience with text,
Material Designer recommends
using a dynamic type, instead
of smaller type sizes or
truncating larger size text.
We made this much easier to
implement with the introduction
of TextView AutoSizing.
Let's see how to use
it, how to customize it,
and what caveats you
need to be aware of.
With Android O and
Jetpack, text view
gained a new property,
auto size text type,
which allows you to
optimize the text size when
working with dynamic content.
To enable auto sizing, set
auto size text type to uniform.
This scales text uniformly on
horizontal and vertical axes,
ignoring the text
size attribute.
When using Jetpack, make sure
you use the app namespace.
Note that you should not use
wrap content for layout width
or layout height for a
text view set to auto size,
since, well, it may
produce unexpected results.
Instead use match
parent or a fixed size.
Turn off auto
sizing by selecting
none instead of uniform.
You can also use auto size
programmatically like this.
If you want to customize
your text view more,
we have some extra
attributes for you.
Auto size min and max, text
size, and step granularity.
The text view will
scale uniformly
in the range between the
minimum and the maximum size
in increments of
step granularity.
If you don't set
these properties,
the default values will be used.
Programmatically these values
can be set via this method.
To have more control
over the final size,
if, for example, your app needs
to comply with specific text
size design guidelines, you
can provide a list of sizes,
and it will use the
largest one that fits.
Create an array with the
sizes in your resources,
and then set the auto size
preset sizes attribute
in the XML.
Or do this in code
by providing an array
of preset sizes and their unit.
Using dynamic sizes
for text views
makes your app more interesting
and helps your users
decode content quickly.
So start using the
auto size property.
Fine tune it as you see fit.
And improve your
user experience.
[SOARING]